[Music]
how are you greeted by cristian cásseres with
his brief information from news now in
spanish we started with a fire that
completely consumed the historic
mauthausen cabins hotel the guests
woke up to emergency calls
asking them to evacuate the hotel it
is 50 miles from the  vegas and units from the
county and city assisted the
manchester fire department to put out the fire it has been in operation
for
over 60 years no one
was injured and the cause of the fire is
still under investigation
and the life is beautiful music festival
will be held this weekend
week it is anticipated that more than 170 thousand
spectators will attend various stages
around downtown las vegas to
enjoy the great artists who will
perform for three days
organizers of the event have taken
additional security measures
the public is advised that they will have to
present proof  of vaccination to
enter or show a
negative test result  s of more than 72 hours
of validity to enter there will also be
a clinic located in las vegas'
bolivar and jail open until nine
o'clock on Friday night
and speaking of vaccination the
iheartradio music festival will also require
viewers proof of vaccination
against the  kobe 19 as well as negat
ve test results this event
will be held at two locations over
he weekend with two venue
one being bovine enzyme and the o
her at the c
unty cork diner that is giving out $100
ift cards
in  a vaccination clinic located
at eldorado high school this
weekend i heard this the first 500
people to get the vaccine on saturday
and sunday will get the card the
clinic is open from
10pm to 4pm clark county states
that  the program could be extended if there is
high participation and we are only days away from
saying goodbye to summer and the
temperatures are already decreasing  or
we will have a slight chance of
storms later this friday and
we will be in the high nineties another
possibility of scattered showers
for saturday morning remember that
fall arrives this wednesday i am cristian
casseres with his informative watch from
news neon spanish good morning
[Music  ]